we have at least 11 million people in
this country that came in illegally they
will go out well you're the only person
on the stage that's ever been fine for
hiring people to work on your projects
illegally when your funding open border
politicians you shouldn't be surprised
when they fight for open borders you
look at our borders they're like Swiss
cheese everybody pours in
i'm not gonna pay for that whoa you
don't get an actual check from the
mexican government how are you going to
make them pay for the wall I will and
the wall just got 10 feet taller believe
me he's got ten feet tall
if he builds the wall the way he built
Trump Towers you'll be using illegal
immigrant labor to do it second